derrière la précarité se cachent des
hommes et des femmes motivé à changer
leur vie c'est le cas de virginie à 55
ans tous les matins elle multiplie ses
quêtes sur les sites de recherche
d'emploi dont ma de menton mes
recherches je ne trouve rien il rien
pour moi
malheureusement dans que c'est pas
évident moi je vais me retourner sur le
pôle emploi depuis huit mois
elle habite cet appartement aux terres
sainville vivent dans 1 35 mètre carré
c'est nouveau pour cet ancien
dermatologue
l'an dernier elle décide de quitter la
france est rentrée en martinique pour
ouvrir son propre cabinet avec ses
économies
elle achète un local mais les choses ne
se passent pas comme prévu suite à une
arnaque dunk williot je lui avais déjà
versé une somme d'argent de 35 dans le
coin 6000 euros par don est ce monsieur
n'à jusqu'à la journée d'aujourd'hui
malgré mes démarches au niveau de la
justice
je n'ai pas eu gain de cause cette
épreuve l'a poussé à changer de secteur
de métier après six entretiens toujours
pas de poste ses seuls revenus
les allocations 721 euros total lorsqu
elle paye ses charges
elle n'a plus les moyens de se faire
plaisir la nourriture que j'ai remis en
place si tout ce que je peux
m'offrir après avoir payé tout ce que
j'ai à pays
partir en vacances pour l'instant je ne
peux même pas pensé à ce long voyage
vacances je ne peux pas je ne peux pas
c'est pas demain pour pallier à ces
difficultés économiques
virgin et se fournit en nourriture ici
dans cette épicerie sociale
les aliments sont vendus à moindre coût
normalement pris on observe un dessert à
1 euro soit à peu près là ici je
l'achète ou 50 centimes d'euro comme
virginie
le secours catholique accompagne plus de
4000 personnes les trois quarts
concernent des familles monoparentales
le nombre de dossiers de demandes que
nous recevons ici a augmenté à augmenter
le budget que nous avions prévu pour
l'année 2018
depuis plus de trois mois on a déjà
dépassé le budget et je peux vous dire
que la situation s'empire
la majorité des personnes accompagnées
par le secours catholique vivent avec
moins de 540 euros par mois en
martinique 26 % de la population vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté
le voile sur cette misère est loin
d'être levé